if you enjoy DC's The Flash take a look
at these cocktails we made inspired by
the heroes of the movie for Batman we
have the Timeless classic the
old-fashioned the old-fashioned is a
great bourbon or whiskey drink that's
weathered Timeless just like the Dark
Knight himself and it's probably the
drink that he'd have Alfred make for him
after a long night of crime fighting
the Supergirl we decided to go with a
dessert cocktail that's mainly vodka
blue Powerade and a scoop of raspberry
sherbet
the drink is sour sweet fizzy and
Incredibly powerful and for the flash we
have the classic Blended strawberry
margarita a glass of this will give you
a nice jolt of energy while making you
feel completely relaxed teams up and
pairs well with any type of meal or
drink that you have with you currently I
really do hope you give one of these
drinks a shot personally I love the
old-fashioned drink responsibly